- [Instructor] Let's say that Y
is equal to sin of X
squared to the third power,
which of course we could also write
as sin of X squared to the third power
and what we're curious about
is what is the derivative
of this with respect to X?
What is DY/DX which we
could also write as Y prime?
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
This isn't a straightforward
expression here
but you might notice that I have something
being raised to the third power,
in fact, if we look at the
outside of this expression
we have some business in here
that's being raised to the third power.
And so, one way to tackle this
is to apply the chain rule.
So, if we apply the chain rule
it's gonna be the
derivative of the outside
with respect to the inside
or the something to the third power,
the derivative of the
something to the third power
with respect to that something.
So, it's going to be three
times that something squared
times the derivative with respect to X
of that something, in this case,
the something is sin,
let me write that in the blue color,
it is sin of X squared.
It is sin of X squared.
No matter what was inside
of these orange parentheses
I would put it inside of
the orange parentheses
and these orange brackets right over here.
We learned that in the chain rule.
So, let's see, we know
this is just a matter
of the first part of the expression
is just a matter of
algebraic simplification
but the second part we need
to now take the derivative
of sin of X squared.
Well, now we would want to
use the chain rule again.
So, I'm going to take the derivative,
it's sin of something,
so this is going to be,
the derivative of this
is gonna be the sin of something
with respect to something,
so that is cosine of that something
times the derivative with respect to X
of the something.
In this case, the
something is our X squared
and of course, we have
all of this out front
which is the three times sin
of X squared, I could write
it like this, squared.
Alright, so we're getting close.
Now we just have to
figure out the derivative
with respect to X of X squared
and we've seen that many times before.
That, we just use the power rule,
that's going to be two X.
Two X and so, if we
wanted to write the DY/DX,
let me get a little bit
of a mini drum roll here,
this shouldn't take us too long,
DY/DX, I'll multiply the
three times the two X
which is going to be six X,
so I've covered those so far
times sin squared of X squared,
times cosine of X squared.
And we are done applying the
chain rule multiple times.